this episode is brought to you by gray
block pizza gray block mm miss ness ness
ness so good also I am back in Toronto
Toronto dates are back on that September
20th through the 22nd now three nights I
will have shows there as well Phoenix
October 27th at the Orpheum Theatre is
on and Nashville Charlotte Appleton
Washington DC Salt Lake City all tickets
available theof on comm slash tour so I
was I had a show the Ice House recently
and I met this beautiful group of people
and they have a small business and and
the small business is something that I
love to do a bunch and it's basically
just talk talk gibberish talk smack and
this they have a new game out it's
called
unruly bastards and and I'll read one of
the cards to you announce the slogan for
your new dildo company get that hitter
that's one for sure
defend your right to diabetes tell us
about the time you saw a unicorn sales
pitch for a medium sized penis these are
all ideas and all part of the themes in
the game
unruly bastards and it's a hilarious
party game for you and your unruly
friends and the people that started it
came out to my comedy show and is really
really sweet of them and they came out
and introduced themselves and we all got
a picture together and and they gave me
this game and we supported their
Kickstarter and that's what it is you
can go to its on Kickstarter it's live
right now we'll put up the link below
and this is your chance to get it and be
the first to own it it's 20 bucks you
support the game and you get the game
that's in you want to find out how
insane and fun your friends really are
go to unruly bastards dot-com and
support their Kickstarter that's it
unruly bastards dot-com man get that hit
up have you ever traveled somewhere if
you haven't it's basically when you go
somewhere else and now if you want to do
that you can use the Act II on packing
cubes to help you stay organized
because just throwing everything in a
suitcase that's really a thing of the
past man that's something your
grandparents would do or somebody that
was you know in the Bible just really
you know it's outdated a little bit so
you got to update your packing styles
and that means these acti on packing
cubes so you could put all your socks or
all your pants in one of these and then
put that into your bag so you know where
everything is gonna be is basically
packing within your packing for somebody
that just likes to have access then you
can put all your dirty clothes into one
of the packing cubes for on your way
home each set of packing cubes includes
two sizes large and small and you can
fit up to two weeks of clothes into one
set so use code Theo at checkout for 40%
off plus free shipping on us orders at
get acti on.com
that's GE t AC t EO n and use code Theo
th e o for 40% off GE ta si te o n
dot-com and code Theo
today's guest is attempting to be the
first woman ever to row a boat across
the Pacific Ocean and that seems super
intense she's an author she is she's
really quite a damsel I think she is
she's a yachts woman she's a captain she
is my guest today miss Leah dictum
[Music]
all right Leah what's up thank you good
and so you flew you flew in you live in
San Francisco now I drove down okay
I this time right but I wrote down in
the summer you did I did and so what's
the difference because the drive here if
I want to drive up to San Fran it takes
me probably maybe seven hours six hours
or something
it's what so rowing is what it took me
12 and a half days days to Santa Barbara
and then three days on to Redondo Beach
okay Wow and do you stop it like a bar
like a like do you pull over like Wendy
how do you are not a bar but do you pull
over and like no no take everything with
you that you need to survive right in
fact I arrived in Santa Barbara with no
food nothing at all no and so are you
planning and I like when you take a trip
do you plan to show up with nothing can
you hear okay now she can bring it just
oh yeah it'll swing all the way to her
jaw yeah yeah it do you like do you plan
that when you're rowing well you'd like
to come in with some spare you got I was
thinking it would take ten days and it
took 12 and a half to Santa Barbara okay
and oh well it's a long extra time it's
a little extra yeah because six or seven
meals extra yeah so I didn't go hungry
but I was going to be hungry quite soon
right and it was a stress that started I
started to feel about halfway through
the trip going oh no you know how to
fake really and it's a it makes it
really edgy you know now you wake up
that little bit earlier you put in that
little bit of extra effort ah but it was
a real test right because I'm training
to row from Japan to San Francisco right
and that could take four to six months
but equally it could take eight months
if I don't wake up that little bit early
and put in that little bit extra and
plan ahead right so to have that edge of
of being kind of possibly hungry soon
yeah so yeah so you get that I'm sure
it's like that feeling of almost like
anything
get lost on a hiking trail is probably a
similar feeling where it's like oh man I
thought there's gonna be two mile hike
and I took a different route and now
it's six miles and so you know suddenly
it's like you know the day is different
and you have to kind of prepare a little
bit differently and you have to wake up
you're just more alert I bet ya you
realize that you have finite resources
yeah you need to manage those carefully
and when you feel like something like
that happens do you feel like that's
almost like it in an eighth thing that
happens inside of us that like there's
like bells and whistles that go off
inside of us that are like it's not even
like I notice if I'm hungry I'm a lot
more alert you know I'm a lot more clear
I feel like I'm I can be frantic at
certain points but I'm also a lot how
good thing he's done a lot faster yeah I
mean it really was no drama right
because essentially you could go to
Monterey you go to some of your Bispo
right you pull in anywhere yeah but then
on a bigger trip though you can't pull
in right yeah you can't no and if you if
you go hungry there's an international
rule of the sea which is that another
ship in the area will divert to help you
oh that's nice so they will drop off
whatever they want to give you right
basically oh wow
have you ever had that happen it's
really funny you ask because we came
quite close to a ship in the North
Atlantic so I'm a captain right that's
what I do and then every four or five
years I do my own crazy project oh I see
so yeah I thought you I mean I pictured
you and for our listeners that don't
know Lea is an author and a we're
correct from I saw I've seen yacht woman
written a it depends what country you're
in over in England your ayaats woman
yachts woman very posh okay yeah but in
America you're a captain really I kind
of like better yeah but you have where
are you a pirate well you have captain
in your name sure that's true my middle
name yes you were born cat and I don't
even like to swim I'm not that good on
the water but and you've you've you
haven't circumnavigated the globe no but
you have gone across the Atlantic nine
times row Indian Ocean three times the
Pacific twice you've been it you've been
out there yeah I go I like it out there
yeah it's a good start
Rana do something like I'm about to and
you're rowing really time your hands go
put your hand
yeah I thought it would be real tougher
well I have this this hand cream that
the Norwegian fishermen use oh really
yeah the man use it to uh well it was
created for the Norwegian fishermen oh
so I guess critical I could see them
using it
power out that probably go through a
little bit of it you know well it you
need to preserve their hands these are
your tools
yeah it's important so when you get out
there so so how long so this is you said
it could be up to four months or eight
months your trip your crossing right
four to six months okay and I'm gonna
take food for five okay there are two
men have done it solo they were both
French and one took 134 days and the
other 137 and then the next one to 134
but they both got towed in to land
really and so do you so technically they
didn't make it well that's what I would
think is that what you think well and I
mean if you've wrote 6,000 miles and you
get towed the last 20 you have to hand
it to the first guy at least right
that's a good point but the second guy
he got towed 50 miles and we got code he
was like I'm gonna draw a line down line
of longitude from where he finished and
call that my finish and then he got
towed 50 miles but he was you know suave
good-looking French guy with a watch
sponsor and so friends you know and his
PR company went in to bat for him oh no
you can't expect him to you know
continue growing after he crossed the
line of the previous guy the French
never finished really no they never
really get all the way there you know
they say they're coming you know it's so
fresh they say they'll be there and then
something that kind of happens towards
the end well the first guy got towed
over the Columbia River Bar which is it
is notorious for destroying boats so do
you think that he took the easy way out
no I think that was the right solution
for that particular guy but the second
guy I think he copped out right but the
first guy ended at Cape Disappointment
no and I know this guy the Jared Avila
and I know he would have enjoyed the
irony of finishing at Cape
Disappointment and having to get towed
over he would have actually enjoyed it
it'd be like the irony of that so when
you're at this you're out there on the
like how different I've been on a cruise
or that went across the Pacific right
that went from
I don't even know where it was it was
from from Vancouver to to walk Kobe Kobe
Japan okay or something or Kyoto someone
go yeah one go right now so but it was a
cruise ship like how different is your
vessel than like a cruise how different
is it that accrues my boat's 21 feet so
about the size of this room
really yeah so that's so you and you do
every position you're the you are the
rower you're the engine you're the
bartender you're the DJ you're
everything right it's like living in
your bathroom
yeah yeah and you can sleep in the cabin
which is about the size of your bathtub
and you have a rowing seat on deck and a
small compartment for storage up front
that's it and are you going backwards
the whole time yeah thank you though get
backwards across the ocean oh we had
this kid when I was growing up they used
to only play he would only run backwards
on the playground yeah something's wrong
with him and then some people ended up
attacking him because it a certain point
it just messes up the flow of everything
it's like oh you know what is this
something wrong with him already turned
out to be a genius and you all had it
wrong I mean we get that could have been
a mess we were all going the wrong
direction you know getting his own path
yeah he may have been do you feel like
you like go against like you're going
against the grain like what like why
like like what are you rowing from like
you've like there's something you're
rowing from like I think there is a
strong undercurrent that's that's
driving me to do this right it has to be
I mean this is now the second year of
training for this
yeah and it'll be three or four before a
total before I do this and there has to
be something really quite compelling to
make you continue to push off to that
goal with all these people that saying
you're crazy what are you doing and you
you know when ASA is like yeah and is
that it is it just like was this just an
idea that you had yeah I guess like why
like what is it that makes you mean I
guess is just like that ain't that thing
inside of a human like that the desire
to achieve like what is it you think
that well I've rowed the Atlantic right
and I rode with another person and that
whole row became about our
ship and getting on on lack of it was
this a man or a woman he's a man and
when you guys lovers or no no he was
married with four kids
really and he fellas he married the
whole time on the day he was married the
whole time of the trip he fell out with
his rowing partner and he traded in this
tall hairy guy for me captain at the
time I just come off a three months
delivery from Cape Town to Abu Dhabi
where we went past pirate pirate area
right and yeah he traded in a captain
young woman for for me I mean for that
guy for me and was he wasn't ready for
that I think though that he fell out
with that partner because it was just
too much I could the idea of rowing the
the Atlantic when it came down to like
that final over the part of left
humanity just jumped in at the last unit
yes really do you think if it hadn't
have been that and since were so I was
like a thing at the LAT like okay now
like that you would not have done it or
you already done it no I hadn't done it
but I was doing that was your first time
I was gonna row in an Olympic rower and
then I met her and she was kind of cold
aloof and Scandinavian I thought this
will never work
yeah but by the time I got to the point
of meeting her I was like what is this
woman done like now I want a row an
ocean this is just mad why because you
were almost in you had envy it was
envious so that she has done it it was
she didn't do it I'm not and certainly
not with me but it was a fascinating new
world people wrote oceans right holy
[ __ ] you know it's so funny like when I
was young actually I remember saying it
they have a company called sea-doo right
which makes like you know these little
things yeah these things you can like
just zoom across the you know the water
or whatever you could Rob ibly if I can
use one of your bathtub if you wanted to
get a big tub and your wife didn't get
mad about a lot of stuff you know but
they had um I sent them a letter
yeah these right there I sent them a
letter asking him I remember being 17 or
something and sent him a letter saying I
wanted to see you around the whole world
and they never say they never wrote me
back
wait oh they have a fundamental problem
of getting refueled endlessly so that's
one problem you would have yeah so
that's one thing about you is you don't
have to stop for fuel you're the fuel I
am I'm the engine right and I had a
hilarious conversation with a ship's
captain like a big you know car carrying
ship and the captain asked me if I was
okay because he said that like I'm like
on megaphones or like how did you do it
by radio so oh okay VHF radio and he
said you know you're I was drifting at
the time yeah but I had rode to get out
of their way and then I had stopped
rowing to have a pee cuz for the entire
two hours of like getting out of their
way again I was dying for a pee but I
was like I need to keep going on the
oars yeah and so when I stopped he'd
passed and now he's asking if I'm okay
because I'm not under command and I go
well like you know you're broadcasting
when you're on the radio and I was like
I just need to take a pee but then I'll
get back on the oars I'm fine
do you feel like he was trying to make
pickup on you a little bit like I like
he thought maybe you were like no I
could see a man being again especially
out on the ocean a woman just happens to
be rowing by which a is an email to an
oceans dream right that is never gonna
happen like you're some kind of like
water like lot lizard or something you
know well I rename the name of my boat
rowboat so that when I transmit my
position I'm loud and clear that I'm a
robot but I still have to explain this
to people right like I'm named rowboat
there's a picture of a rowboat what part
of this do you not get but when I'm on
the radio you know I'm a young woman I
have a British accent I'm alone in a
rowboat yes I'm often me Carmen Sandiego
yeah I feel like that's who I feel like
I feel like holy [ __ ]
a real-life Carmen Sandiego is showing
up cuz it must be I mean you're
basically I think especially a man out
on the ocean
they're just fantasy they're you know
they're just stuck out there with
usually mostly men you know so the idea
that a woman's gonna go by in a rowboat
and needs rescuing yeah of course
yeah like this woman out of the out of
the ocean that's the first thing I would
think of think you ever run across any
of that on the radios where men would
like they seem like you got a little
flirty I'm sure
not really but the Coast Guard sometimes
my biggest problem because they want to
rest they go fast and they creep up on
you and they don't transmit always and
oh yeah sometimes I row naked yeah and
then I'm in this flurry to get dressed
which looks
oh yeah so they slow down because now I
look suspicious of course so I'm waiting
till they go so I can you know get back
to being naked and rowing I say and why
naked like what is it just easier naked
you don't have as much chafe under the
arms right and you don't have to do any
laundry and there's no one else around
and I mean it's not always warm enough
but the entire Atlantic crossing we were
naked from the beginning really yeah and
got our best tan you did yeah and so
that was the first time that you um that
you went right and that was with a
partner and then you did it two more
times by yourself no no that was it that
was it yeah and now I'm training for
this position crossing but it was magic
the Atlantic yeah and I mean that was
the 9th time I'd been across and most of
the other boats were fast boats so with
this was that was the first time you've
been across rowing I'm sure agus okay
yeah and what's the difference between
like rowing and and going fast
well wrote in a rowboat you are super
close to the water like the very thing
that I feared that proximity to the
ocean was the thing I ended up loving
hmm and these oars are like extensions
of your arms so you can feel the water
you can feel these different textures
and you think that a flat C would be the
best rowing but it isn't because you
have to cut the surface rip the water
and then get momentum going with the
boat but when the there's some wind and
the waves are aerated it's light and
fluffy and it's like rowing through silk
and I didn't know there were ocean had
texture right and underneath the water
so every week you need to get in the
water and clean the bottom of the boat
you do yeah and there's not like a place
there's nobody stopping by this I don't
know you can use to be like is the
scariest part the whole thing is I'm now
gonna get out of the thing that's
keeping me alive I would put my feet up
and clean the bottom of the boat Wow and
at that point do you kind of wish you
had somebody else you could flip a coin
to see who would do it
well well when I was wrong somebody else
I couldn't wait to put some distance
between the two of us so I loved it
under there and what you don't realize
is that because you are so slow-moving
is there's a whole ecosystem underneath
your boat that are using your shadow for
protection No yeah so it's like 50
under the boat and you need to keep that
ecosystem in check because if stuff grow
on the bottom of the boat then fish come
to eat those and bigger things get out
well you know it yeah you have your
Marlin and and you know these bill fish
bearing around you you're just a little
awning for a dang you're just an awning
for this and just shark or something or
something Iger I know you gotta keep it
small the chain but we got to keep that
chain smoking grow big exact I mean you
could get here and have damn Poseidon
under there if you prefer nothing off by
the end you know you could be an
umbrella you could be an umbrella for
Poseidon yeah but doing it by myself
I haven't done it yet like I I need
something on the list so it's a trainer
so you haven't even trained for that
part of you yeah out cleaning the but no
but you missed and that's the most
dangerous part because that is when you
were I mean outside of that you're not
in the water
if you it's at if you are detached from
the boat you are dead
like it just takes one or two waves to
in drift to separate you in the boat
it's a wrap
yeah it's a wrap and the boat don't know
you like that the boat will keep going
yeah doesn't care so you you know you
need a strap on your wrist or a harness
or whatever makes you feel confident
that that you'll stay with your boat
it's it's your shell right you were the
hermit crab it's your shell I see and do
you feel like like what starts to change
after being out in the water devil like
I can start to I can feel when you said
that the oars feel like part of your
arms right like I can really feel that
um like I could feel I got us you know
just how you start to become do you feel
as human do you feel more or less human
do you feel more like a boat you feel
more connected to nature like what's
some of that kind of stuff that goes on
inside of you and inside as you go along
on the ocean I mean because just have
that much of a relationship with
something I don't know if I've been in a
relationship for six months you know
much less like we're just like you know
skirting on the top of some water you
know I think you lose identity because
there is no mirror I don't take a mirror
and you actually get a lot of feedback
from yourself by our interaction like
right now you're getting information
little tiny parcels of it about
right now from our conversation which I
don't get if I if there are no other
humans hmm so that just falls away
I think identity an ego fall away but
maybe not so much ego but definitely
identity and Wow identity falls away
that's fascinating and also your whole
body becomes a tool so instead of
walking like on two legs now you have
two arms and two legs and you use them
almost equally to move around to brace
yourself and your seat is moving as you
do this it's very similar to a rowing
machine at the gym yes but there's a lot
more wobble sideways stuff and what does
your butt start to hurt after a while
yes
or does it feel is it here ever like
erotic feeling at all or no no and you
kind of you need to fatten up before you
go oh really
big time I've gained 30 pounds I need to
get another 15 Wow well the 30 you have
looks nice I mean I didn't I only look I
only look at our guests and I look neck
up for yes but it's like I mean have you
ever met a woman who said I am gonna
gain 45 pounds said like no woman ever
well you see if they do better
some men would be like well you better
be heading out to see honey right so and
then you come back stripped of it I'll
lose 40 50 pounds so there's a suitors
waiting at the shoreline
you probably throws is oh my god walk
right you have a locker for five months
yes and your sense of stability your
balances is completely changed like you
walk around like a drunk person crashing
into stuff it huh and land seems so hard
and unforgiving oh wow call it flat land
is it just you move your foot down and
it doesn't move and do anything yeah do
you feel like you become more is there a
certain type of animal or something that
you feel like you can relate to almost a
little bit more in that kind of moment
cuz that's really interesting that
you're at the water for so long that
then the land doesn't feel like home you
know it's it's an odd feeling I think
you know it if you've ever done so many
laps in a pool and then you get out and
there's that like legend feeling there's
like too much gravity suddenly that's
the closest I can say that it feels like
but you yeah you feel quite wild yeah
I mean I used to pluck my eyebrows and
then I rode the Atlantic and I didn't
pluck them during the Atlantic and
afterwards I was like why would I waste
my time right plucking my eyebrows again
you know so things just change after
that and do you um cuz I remember I went
on this thing called semester at sea
right I used to work in the bookstore
I've seen those but boats around the
world have you yeah not just like when
you're out there huh
I saw one docked in Mauritius oh cool
very cool yes we've done that it was a
neat experience I got a job in the
bookstore and the financial aid that I
had applied at I went to Louisiana State
University that applied on this ship so
you want a student I wanted a student
yeah oh okay but you also working on bud
yeah but also working on board and so I
mean it was you know it's like 700
students and you're just basically you
kind of go around the globe when you
stop at different ports and I did notice
like at a certain point we started to
become our own little piece of the world
that had gone loose and we and we
developed our own little system of who
not who was in charge about what was
acceptable and what was okay and I
noticed we started
honestly wearing less and less clothes I
noticed at the end of the cruise at the
end of the ship but like you could
almost wear nothing to class and it was
acceptable to everyone men and women
like things became very just a lot more
natural once we were separated from from
America and also noticed like out on the
ocean it would just like the days just
seemed to kind of go by like what is it
like for you out there do things go fast
do things go slow when you're out on the
water like does time change at all as
compared to here on land does it feel
like it yeah there's a 24-hour clock now
rather than a 12-hour clock and I
haven't been doing this now for 17 years
being a captain I've noticed that I
don't eat at regular times in fact
that's not natural to me to have
breakfast at I don't know 7:00 to 9:00
and lunch at noon and then dinner
it's not natural my Bret natural
breakfast time is somewhere between
midnight 3:00 3:00 a.m. Wow and then I
have a second breakfast like 7:00 which
is really lunch and then my natural
dinner is noon and then the whole
afternoon evening
she naturally don't want to eat that
time huh and you just found that that's
when you that's when you work best yeah
that's what my body wants if completely
left to it right so there are yeah there
are rules and guidelines that we are
imposed upon us that actually might not
be through your your rhythm and you find
those things out wow that's so cool but
every day at sea I feel is so different
like I feel I have the best front row
seat in the world's greatest cinema yeah
you know the Sun rises the Sun sets the
wildlife all of that and I think that if
I don't write about it it's lost right
so I try and and write every single day
to take everyone with me cuz I'm gonna
go where I don't know 95% of the world
will never go yeah so I I aw do blog so
I write blogs by read them okay and and
they go directly and post that same day
correct and they have a lat/long they
have a position right I come up as a
little message on my track so people can
see where you're at and they can do that
all through your website correct okay
but I want to be your eyes in your ears
I want to tell you what it feels like
the senses and and take you on that
journey with me do you
does your do you feel more or less like
a woman after you're out on the ocean
for a long time and I'm just in question
do you feel like cuz you said kind of
your identity goes away and I don't mean
it in any so you know bass way or
anything like that
but do you do you feel yeah do you feel
more just like a human and not like a
woman or a man like that that makes any
sense I don't really hang on to that but
and there may be no answer I don't know
I'm just trying to like think about if I
were out there for so long and so to
test you know from the society and just
write you know the regular systems and
norms that were in and all these little
circles that we function in and you
mentioned identity like what would kind
of change about me when I was out there
for so long do you know I think I
thought about that before I read the
Atlantic because even though I was naked
I wore a necklace and I felt that hung
on to my femininity in some way and so I
think that that answers I think you do
lose it
you know you're neither male nor female
you're just this a wild human Wow
do you feel start to feel wild I do and
I feel I love the feel of the breeze on
my naked skin hmm it's like an edge I
call it an air shower and is that the
only kind of shower you can really take
out there man we can just jump in the
you in the water but or can you jump in
the water well again your your jumping
off your craft
so that's risk with caution I have a
desalinator so I make water I press the
salt out of the water and so I can wash
but everything you do is an economy of
effort if you go up to the front cabin
that's a movement that you don't
necessarily need to make if you don't
need it everything needs to be
considered to economize on effort
because if you're going to do 9 to 12
hours of exercise a day that's going to
take everything you've got and you want
to keep your mental capacity enough that
you can make good decisions and navigate
their life do you and at any point did
you start to lose that any only in your
tracks lose a mental clarity
yeah like did you start to feel like oh
something's going on here it could have
been a mix of like the motor the
movement in the ocean or you know an
illness coming on or some type of a
vertigo or something you start to feel
that all are you were always on well I'm
trained captain so I'm pretty sharp on
that but but coming down the coast in
June I rode past Point Conception and
had one of the most harrowing nights of
my life at sea and that night even
though my experience told me what I
needed to do and I did those things and
I didn't ever feel that I was risking my
life but I also knew from experience
that I was in a very dangerous situation
yeah that if I didn't do this thing that
my experience was telling me to do I
need dire things could could happen
ultimately waves were breaking clean
over my boat really and if that wasn't
bad enough I had rowed all day and now I
was awake all night so what happened was
the Santa Anas turned on like this freak
40 mile an hour blast of a hundred
degree heat just off the land like that
and it mashed it created wind waves that
mashed into the prevailing current and
just this you know nightmare because
are you and at that point you do you sir
knows right next to land really which is
even more scary more dangerous because
and in front of the shipping lane
there's now stuff that can hit you and
you can hit it mmm and you just get into
like a survival mode like okay this
happens and this happens and I just an
idea yes just keep going but I went
through into the different modes of
severe sleep deprivation and the first
for me is paranoia like I hear voices
people oh you haven't seen people for
1215 days so you're like people who are
their sighted people and then you open
the hatch and you know for well there
are no people but you open the hatch and
you check every single time that's
awesome so you almost love that though a
little bit like it's a little bit
exciting even though it's scary
well no no but it just it went on and it
escalated through the night because one
thing happened after another and at one
point I had to bring in the scene
because there's a big parachute that
minimizes your drift and I'm pulling it
into these breaking waves and I look
right it's to my forward cabin and I see
the hatch and there's a little hand
trying to get out no way and I'm like
that's not real like at that point my
brain could separate and say no that's
not real don't freak out it wasn't real
don't freak out this hand that's like
this big trying to push out like coming
out of the cabin it's not all on boy or
a golem out there beautiful wow that
would be so have you ever has a fish
ever just jumped right into you flying
fish yeah yeah they jump in the boat and
you know they don't know what's going on
you I personally have them but other
people and on past crossings have and
it's always really funny and they smell
this stink they do they totally stink oh
and they leave scales everywhere and
then they go crazy and you're like stop
it I'm gonna say if you just stop moving
alright pick him up by the wing and
they've they you know you jump fly me
clapping in the woods what gets in the
boat like from the out so that's water
what's a waves splashing in and usually
just at that point where you've washed
your socks and you're like no
no new low like we just got just got dry
sucks and now that wet again yeah could
can the smallest thing be like the
biggest thing out there like like it
could it be like that the smallest thing
that that's that's your entire day it
seems like sometimes you're just kind of
getting wet when you're not prepared for
it is the worst it's the worst I mean I
open the hatch to in that particular
scenario we had to bring the the sea
anchor on board the little hand appeared
and then a wave just the timing of it
just came over my head and I was like
new low just drenched clean over and
especially at night because you have to
wait until the Sun comes out to even get
dry you have to get over it really
quickly you know it happened
I'm over it yeah I'm not wet so what do
you um do you have any different dreams
out there that you noticed or anything
like that or do you dream more you have
really clear dreams yeah they've
sometimes dreaming and reality are
almost as clear and sharp and you're not
sure the first crossing I ever did
across the Indian Ocean I hitched a ride
on a boat back from Thailand and yeah
the the the night visions were just
phenomenal
I'm meeting myself inviting myself and
then giant chess sets and birds and I
was a bird I mean it was wild I suppose
something the water a lot of people do
don't you know yeah yeah I have a lot of
Pizza dream it's like I want to really
drop pizza that's my fantasy and it's
like I want the the fiorentino you know
the one with the egg and it's sorry
don't [ __ ] with the egg you know drop
that thing well and when I was rowing
across the Atlantic I was getting near
Antigua and I knew I had a friend who
had a plane and I was to do it you know
come on dropping the pizza be somebody
and my friends are like what do we do
they just decided we're not gonna reply
just don't reply don't go there I was
like I know you've got a plane what that
pizza well we do get a medium no the
largest pizza you can imagine oh no be
greedy you just Rowan you know and you
look up at planes going on what their
foods like you know I bet do you ever
look at a point you're just so jealous
huh
no usually my foods better really it
used to be different but
in-flight food now it's not gotten bad
yeah but do you look up at a plaintiff
like [ __ ] that's way I should have done
that instead no no I'm too far down the
path now yeah you know life's taking a
lot of left turns and now we are where
we are you know yeah I can't look back
some of the ocean life like recent we
had a guest on this guy named Jay Mohr
and he was I think the first guest we
ever had on this podcast and he and he
took me paddleboarding out he lives on
the Pacific like on the PCH somewhere
and he took me paddleboarding out and
kayaking right off from his house I got
it and I'd never realized like the
seaweed comes up to the top sometimes
and you're just it just it's it was one
of the most fascinating moments I've had
like being that far out in the water we
weren't very far out but couple hundred
yards and being just seeing like
dolphins and seeing seals go by and just
it blew my mind like I didn't realize I
had this moment of like wow like water
is really the king like land is this
sort of second-class citizen on the
earth yeah really it should be planet
ocean if you look at the map it's blue
and we call it planet Earth but earth is
in minority yeah to the ocean do you
start do like do you develop any
relationships with like animals that are
out there like how long will an animal
do you really yeah how long will an
animal like kind of just cruise
alongside like you you ever get a seal
that's you know seem like he's been
trying to be naughty or something not
like crazy but like I seal you know it's
a man and he's just milling around for a
couple days
well um dolphins are like the dogs of
the sea oh yeah and I like a dog that
sits at your feet when you're not
feeling so great
dolphins will come and hang out for
hours they don't on a sailboat but
there's something about the Robo you
don't make a noise you don't make a
smell they actually think you might be
one of them really yeah I've had whales
trying to communicate with the boat you
can hear the sonar ping there's like and
you're like I don't speak like I'd like
to but I don't know you're saying and
don't mate with me that's yes yeah cuz I
I was on about now he's a seaman right
out know they take a run at you yeah
wow that's an old-school matter that's
right
but I had a whale try and mate with the
middle hull of my trimaran oh and why
did you paint like a vagina dunno it was
painted blue it must look like a whale
and it turned up and I'm like every time
you see where we go whales yes you know
it's so or inspiring and then this whale
was getting excited just blowing you
know blowing water up you show-off
yeah he's in the dance sequence and he's
doing this this circle round the poking
and I'm like oh don't crush my boat you
know it's not Moby Dick can't destroy my
boat and I'll be swimming do you feel
like at that point like you try to shake
the boat a little like to like you know
no you make a lot of noise you do you
are now a human impersonation of an
outboard motor you are just like
flashing lights you know jumping up and
down feeling I am NOT a whale it's
really wet yes hey yeah I guess you
don't want to shake the boat too much
mood that might give it the wrong signal
biggest you just want to act like not of
it like basically not feminine I'm not a
whale yes this is yes I'm not a whale
that's that's it and so he went
eventually but you know like most males
of the species he came back in the
morning
this morning I had to go through that
whole thing again bro literally I rode
this ship has road yeah we have some
calls that came in and we're gonna keep
talking uh but we I just want to get
some our listeners were really intrigued
and so we had some just some calls that
came in to when I get some of those Nick
anything it pops in your head to you
feel free to ask Leah will do helium
deal my name's ray I'm calling you from
Victoria British Columbia Canada
I'm also a man national rowing team here
so I kind of know what you're preparing
yourself with even though you're going
for a much relative distance Leah but my
two questions for you are how if you
physically prepared for this challenge
but more importantly and the one I'm
more interested in is how you mentally
prepare for this challenge
it's quite an
to undertake best of luck I'm going to
be keeping track watching you do this
banging I've absolutely incredible it's
going to be a really cool experiment
thank you so physically I mentioned the
weight wrong way yeah I put on weight
but ideally you want muscle not fat but
obviously towards the end you just pile
on as much fat as you can you were like
I'm going it's a full-time job if you're
gonna fatten up which isn't really eat
breakfast followed by second breakfast
followed by lunch followed by second
lunch followed by dinner and this
doesn't leave a lot of time do you feel
yeah that's true professional eater at
this point you know you almost need a
restaurant to sponsor that's what I did
with the Atlantic I would love it if we
could get a pizza dropped off to you
somewhere yeah absolutely amazing and
maybe we'll put that clip out and see if
we can get somebody respond to that that
would be a pick and airdrop pizza who
would be a Papa John's needs to rebrand
their image I think that's a tough go
that could be his comeback yeah that
could be yeah do you is that an
uncomfortable feeling having to put on
the weight like being a lady and having
to do that like is it uncomfortable
feeling or is it just fun or what is
that ah it's depressing actually and I
moved out to San Francisco to train in
the Bay of San Francisco and 99% of the
clothes I brought with me do not fit
anymore yeah and what I also learned is
that fat is really indiscriminate my
even my feet bigger oh really yeah
a lot of yeah Vaughn I like him yeah man
this is a little bit of a leopard in the
water right here an excuse for me to
dress up so I do weight training but
interestingly when I first started this
two years ago I did about six hours of
heavy weights per week it was killing me
yeah and just with just the the its
extensive yeah it's brutal on the body
on the nervous system the whole thing
and since January I've been working with
Under Armour they've been writing my
program and we've just eradicated most
of the weight lifting really nearly all
of it you still feel great and I've had
huge gains since doing that so and I
think for some women just serious weight
weightlifting isn't the right thing yeah
it's I mean you see some of these ladies
is just so Jack you know and they're all
it's society too much testosterone
your vagina's getting a little hard this
is getting out of hand
can't comment on that that might have
been a little obtuse - I'm sorry but we
knocked out the rowing machine
I do not row on the rowing machine you
don't know I rode you beat it I train in
my boat and so I'm training volume
ultimately I want to be doing a 70 to 75
our rowing week okay so I need to get to
the point where I can sit in my butt for
75 hours of rowing and that's all you
get your butt your butt has to be ready
yeah it needs to be padded and it needs
to be good solid muscle if it you can
and it does like my butt my body feels
amazing and it feels amazing from the
training because it's all connected now
you know like when you lift up an arm
you feel the muscles working all the way
inside yeah like it's a really cool
feeling if that's a motivation - for
everyone to Train yeah I can't you know
it's hard to even relay what that feels
like but no it's interesting to hear
that you went from weights because
that's like kind of an art it's not our
cake method of lifting but it's
definitely you know like when I was
growing up that was the only method that
they had really you know just when I get
strong yes weight that was it and then
now there's a lot more technology around
Fitness and so what are some of the
things that you would do now that are
different before than you were doing
when you were doing weights so our
philosophy now is do the opposite if I'm
rowing in a linear fashion everything I
want to do should be lateral sideways so
that's one thing a lot of elastic
resistance band stuff because yeah yeah
you're using a safe force and it's in
opposition to to what you were doing and
that yeah literally it is the muscle so
if you want these muscles who you also
want those muscles as well and focusing
on weaknesses so we started with my
ankles and now we're doing working out
with wrong angles well really nothing
that's what I thought that's what I'm
saying but yeah but when you stand they
are the foundation of your balance yeah
so if really yes mine are just kind of
around there I feel like no so if you're
gonna get strong right up to the
shoulders you have to start with the
feet oh god it's the last thing I wanted
to hear today well for what I'm doing
just feel like more pressure it's all
right don't try you
really great well I doesn't want to be
in the gym like this yeah you'll get a
different kind of attraction yeah yeah
it could be different and so he also
said mentally is there's things that you
do are there like actual exercises you
do mentally or is it just your
enthusiasm in your previous experience
and being a captain it's your time on
the water that that's kind of all the
training that you need no I think he's
right it's a really good question I
think you get a lot of you build
confidence by doing the thing and doing
it in increments where you can recover
and go okay that didn't turn out well
like for example I'm trying to set a
record around the Farallon Islands up in
San Francisco and then I'm gonna set
another one new record no one's done it
around Catalina Island down here but the
Farallones one is tough because it's a
chain of islands they're named after
Farrell owners Spanish the devil's teeth
oh yeah and they look gnarly and they're
shocked breeding ground between May and
September hmm just that that yeah spice
but and the bay has this huge tidal and
current patterns and I've not succeeded
twice I mean literally you go out there
and you get whipped and by not
succeeding what does that look like like
what is that you don't get out there as
far and now you're in just survival mode
to get back in and trying to avoid
getting rescued or towed and so and so
those are really the kind of things that
take you out of actually you feel like
achieving it getting rescued or towed
yeah yeah but it's it's so much your
French well at some point they are the
right thing to do and then you just move
on to that that's a new phase now we did
our best and now it's a necessity is
there like do you have as many sexual
desires and you're out on the water as
you do this like in regular day well
yeah I think it's interesting you know
like well I mean I talk we talk a lot
about that kind of stuff on this show
sometimes but it's like do you does any
of that kind of stuff go away like as
any well this was a concern rowing the
Atlantic with a married guy right right
and so I think he asked the race
director you know what
what do we do about that because you're
in international waters you don't mean
I'm not anything but I am saying this
that marriage certificates not gonna
hold up out there you know the saying
off the coast we didn't get on so it was
fine
brah his wife was safe but the race
director said look if you're not if you
feel horny you're not rowing hard enough
oh wow and he was right in that case
where I never I never had any time at
all you just rowing gasps yeah yeah but
hey I'm by myself now right
so do you is that any part of your
journey like you like is that almost
like a I'm gonna treat myself tonight to
a little you know I'm just gonna you
know no downtime yeah literally yeah
yeah well just remember you know row in
a different direction
like what is that light up there cuz I
looked it I'll be in a hotel room and uh
I'll be in there for a half hour and
I'll masturbate I am under said out of
days in but if you I can't even admit
super tired you're not gonna do that you
just go to the bed and pass out restroom
so Dan that's what it's like that's the
norm but I mean I get a lot of jokes of
you know you're gonna take enough
batteries yeah what do you know oh you
know you charge them right but on your
birthday you probably have to master it
on your birthday obviously but I would
I'm starting to think that maybe
actually masturbating is good for your
sports performance because I'm starting
to come get really interested in
hormones and what they do yeah and this
is a whole field I think that's gonna
explode in the future and particularly
for women because I've asked a lot of
the top sports physiologists and they
they've never really had that question
hmm
yeah no I mean that's some of the stuff
that I'm thinking about yeah it's like
how do you kind of does that change like
what change is like in you when you get
separated and you like because it seems
like you would almost you know cuz where
our bodies are 80% water or something
you know or probably ninety percent if
you're my uncle he's an alcoholic but
and most of it's beer so he's definitely
keeping some for himself you know his
cells are definitely storing but um but
it's like when you're out there with
water you're so close to what you are I
just wonder if we know what change is
inside of you you know like do some
things get adjusted you know I mean
times of just like yeah hormones and
like the things you think and like you
know your dreams the way that you
your body feels I mean I don't know it's
just who else is out on water like that
you do feel you start to belong in the
ocean and in fact after that you know
real intense survival night of Santa
Barbara I came in to Santa Barbara July
4th weekend it was a zoo and I never
felt that I was there with these people
or now longer back at the ocean I was
really adrift like him I one of them
yeah I was lost he's bluffing yeager bah
I'm not that and I'm not out there
anymore like what am i and for a few
days I was really in not a great place
with that concept is there moment for
like I could imagine us waking up at
night and it's just like the moon is out
and it's just pretty just gnarly that
was like I remember when I was on this
cruise ship that was one of the coolest
things that I ever saw it
would be out there and seeing like a
meteor shower or something like I'm
where they woke us up all one night and
put us on let us go on the top top deck
and we could all just lay up there in
our sleeping bags for the whole night
Wow and and there was some like you know
once in a jillion years meteor shower or
something and we got to watch and I've
never seen anything like that before
like these huge you know huge shooting
stars
you must witness some stuff like that
her at night you're in you're shutting
it down
I am so low because it makes more sense
to row during the day the human growth
hormone kicks in a couple of hours after
you go to sleep and you need that to
recover so Solo actually I sleep at
night I mean I don't just go okay it's
dark and I go to sleep I I row sometimes
till midnight and I love those
gradations of light you know the sun's
down and now it's sort of silvery and
rolling and and then these different
kind of Neapolitan colors and then the
stars come out and they were all around
the globe over the night - how quiet
does it get out there it's never quiet
no never and that's one of the things
that's so great when you arrive on land
and those silence is that rushing water
is constant
I mean if when there is no sound in an
ocean it is so eerie it is it's so eerie
like I've been in the middle of the
Indian Ocean the loudest thing was me
brushing my teeth like oh my goodness
it's the Truman Show
yeah the ladder gonna pop down good
afternoon good evening here and
sometimes you get phosphorescence in the
water
you have dolphins going by and they're
like these silver torpedoes and you
think you're tripping or there are
amoebas or organisms in the water like
these pulsing things so just so sci-fi
and futuristic and you go no one will
believe me unless I video it and I can't
video because it's night so no one will
believe me
and now I don't yeah and I'm in this
other world you know does any animals
make you feel horny out there you think
like well yes it does well like an
absence so even that way like if it's
trying to incite that action with the
boat you know yeah and I think this
whale obviously has issues if it's
trying to if it's trying to do sex with
boats to me that's out of line like I'm
sure the other whales are like Ernesto
has lost his fat ones Quinn yeah was a
bit much but does that kind of but even
just having that energy come around does
that do you notice any of that in you
does it do you feel any of that or no I
not sexually but there's a kinship like
I have this reoccurring dream that this
whale adopts me because it's lost its
calf oh my god and this whale kind of
follows me across the whole Pacific in
it I get quite emotional even reliving
it sometimes but I've had that dream
many times in the whale when my boat
starts to roll in a storm the whale kind
of flicks it back the other way and and
then at the end of the dream of a see I
have this separation problem because
I've got to go in the Bay of San
Francisco and the whale stays outside
and and it's really sad and then years
later you see each other like it up at a
at an aquarium no no don't don't ruin it
okay but I have this this part of the
dream where I swim out to it with the
line attached to my boat and I just lie
on top of this whale no and and I think
I'll be great that happened so if you
could make that happen
yeah and the pizza's already yeah Peter
gets trapped in that whale probably I
knows what his plans are their therapy
to recover from that yeah I'm on the
whale and the pizza comes out of the sky
can you imagine
that's fascinating
no but sometimes whales cry at night do
they yeah they're looking for one
another or I had one night it must be
hard to find each other in the ocean I
mean they they they communicate we just
we're not on that wavelength yeah
literally yeah but still whales like
like if away like and you said you can
hear them communicating with each other
yeah they when they blow the air out
they can sometimes make a noise with
that ah like really wild sound and it's
it's sort of unsettling and what animal
seems the most creepy I think it's seals
dude a lot of people think seals are
cute and sea lions sea lions yes the
daddies and then I had one that Herbert
block next to me was like Jesus new
jumped off my seat you're alcoholics a
lot of them they look like alcoholics so
they have like ten wives yeah I mean ten
mama gaining weight they're Persian I
think a lot of who knows where they're
from but I've played games with seals
before do you so now do you give them
like yeah will there be moments where
you'll give them treats or like do you
keep anything on the boat where you can
feed an animal no no so I just do my
thing and I row and if they want to
interact that's that's a different
matter like one played hide-and-seek
with the back of the boat so it's kind
of swim there and then it was like
literally jump on a pop-up over the top
of the cabin and I would pop up two and
then it would disappear we were playing
this game and I'm like oh playing a game
with this seal let's just five do you
what do you miss whim underneath
sometimes oh yeah yeah and they go we're
gonna come like there's so much energy
they have going and sometimes they show
off like the Dolphins group splosh you
know like it I can see world and
beginner about the training yeah
oh wow and then you feel like you're
part of this like circus menagerie and
all of these animals are now coming to
show like 5 o'clock poof it could just
be performance around you and you just
feel oh my god is this for me is this
for me yeah and that's the stuff I like
to write because kids oh my god it's so
great for kids to hear about me in this
interaction with this amazing with these
animals in the ocean do you feel like
one of them whether you like an animal
at that moment yeah I mean what you're
the audience or both and you want to
play you want to be part of it I I just
I'd love to really just jump in the
water and see what happened but did you
ever feel like you're will add that to
the list
jumping into clean the bottom and
jumping in the next animal show you know
just to see if you see what happy make
the team I'm coming with you and that
was seal sorry about rowing
like uh do you ever feel like you almost
get so connected that you wish you could
just jump in and just hold your breath
and just go with him yeah I mean not in
those moments because you know I'm now I
become quite bonded with my boat but oh
really
yeah I got to look after this thing this
thing will look after me it's our
relationship but yeah I don't want to go
and join the animal menagerie at this
point right but I did chase after a
shark one time the first time I ever saw
a shark and it was in the Bahamas and I
was like oh we're so beautiful
that was the stunning thing and then I
followed it and there was a baby one I
was like oh dear you know get away from
this but the first instinct wasn't fair
it was like wow and I started snorkeling
swimming after green what are you doing
Leah don't don't follow the shock but
you just felt like your that was your
instinct to disengage it was just so
beautiful fascinating yeah it was
fascinating yeah I remember one time I
went to South Africa one time when we
were swimming with sharks right and just
like out in the cage as you know you did
that
yeah but they had a they had a great
white that was maybe 12 feet long or
something got stuck between they had two
of those cages you could get down in and
one of them and where the cages they
were both round two separate round
circles where they were up against the
boat there was a little area in between
the edge of the boat and the two round
the two round cages and so a shark got
stuck in there oh and he was furious
dude I've never seen anything so mad
I've seen maybe a friend of mine uh a
buddy of Mines mom got that [ __ ] mad
one time but um but other than that I've
never seen anybody get that mad and uh
but I got to touch it like on its head
like its head was like was it slimy you
always got to pet it you know what it
felt like it just I felt like I was so
scared I couldn't feel oh really so it
felt like I couldn't even feel it like
my feelings whatever those were that are
in your feet and your fingers my
feelings are like [ __ ] you you can put
your hand out there we're staying way up
in your elbow you meant to cut off yours
that but yeah yeah my feelings are like
[ __ ]
I'm out Wow but it was pretty
fascinating some of them feel like suede
oh really yeah because I went to a tuna
festival in the South of France one time
and they were I mean just height of the
ceiling and every now that I knew from
is it you know but it's somebody fished
out a baby shark by mistake and so all
the kids were there trying to pull his
teeth out yes so fresh but it was it was
its coat was like suede and it didn't
feel wet or slimy it was it was grown
and magic it's so French pull out of I
put him in your pudding when they
wouldn't come out yeah of course they
wouldn't I wouldn't come out for the
French either dude those teeth I'm tired
of getting wild emails from people that
I don't even want people wanted me to
buy sausages or car parts you know or
buy sod from Vietnam a lot of this has
to stop and now it can with sanebox
we're all so inundated with emails that
we can't even respond everything so why
not organize your inbox
well sandbox does the work for you
sifting only the important emails into
your inbox and directing all the other
distracting stuff into your sane later
folder it also has a special feature
called the sane black hole where you can
drag messages from annoying senders you
never want to hear from again okay you
know what I'm saying aunt Janet trying
to get me to buy these extra tricycle
parts for you no never again see how
SaneBox can magically remove
distractions from your inbox with a free
two week trial
just visit sanebox si in EB Oh XCOM
slash Theo today to start your free
trial and receive a $25 credit that's si
in EB Oh XCOM slash Theo have you ever
been to Texas well now you can go there
almost you can have this hat that says
Texas Austin on it and this is by hood
hat and hood hat makes her swaggy upper
pieces you know they have all kinds of
beautiful top hitters and you think it
says autism and it doesn't you can also
support autism if you want separately
but this hat says Texas Austin and this
is the legend collection and this is
from hood hat and they have all types it
says they have one that says um Death
Valley for LSU they have jordan-hare for
Auburn they have Davis Wade from
Mississippi State
the big house from Michigan the
horseshoe for Ohio State
etc etc they are unique and authentic
they also have hats for baseball teams
New York Yankees Cincinnati Reds and I
love them I really really love a man
they're great if you want to put your
head inside of something and you don't
want it to be something super dangerous
you can get a hood hat you can follow
them on Instagram at Hood hat USA and
you can visit Hood hat calm and use
promo code labor 18 for 20% off that's
that Labor Day hitter Hood hat us a
visit Hood hat calm and code labor 18
labor 1:8 for 20% off what is um you
have a family of a family or know what
husband children no no I don't think you
could to do what I'm yeah that's what I
was thinking do the French guy did the
Foley I shared ever bill yeah but I
don't think that would be acceptable for
a woman we're an edgy territory here
kids people be outraged they know that
you left your kids to you if you go and
you have kids no one know notices right
kids will probably miss their mother
more too well depending on how close
they are to either parent that's true
and depending on what age they are to
yeah I guess they were a week old I
think it would be wrong it would be a
bit much it would just be wrong to take
the breast milk assuming that's working
you know moms run it off with the
groceries I was going to see yeah she's
had the baby now it's yo let's look out
do you feel like that something like do
you feel yeah I guess it would be hard
to do and still is it like a balance or
something you traded you ever want kids
or no I'd like kids yeah I still like
them yeah I'm not sure I'm dateable with
this project yeah yeah like do you have
to tell guys like is that well I know
usually but right
and they get always this they know when
you're at the bar just like yes I'm
doing this over it you always say the
same thing but you're going to see and I
go yes but for four months
yeah yeah those days are over waiting
for months yeah people aren't waiting
that long for love anymore oh dear this
this is depressing it's interesting
because yeah you all you're like it's
almost like the closest thing is like
somebody going into the military going
off for that long really just women put
up with it all the time
right you go on a tour of Afghanistan or
whatever what are you gone six months
yeah so it's not uncommon no no it's not
uncommon I think it's I think it's super
in but there's also the ego thing you're
going not me hmm and you're gonna
achieve this thing not me so I think
it's multifaceted yeah I could see that
especially then if you're leaving
someone and then they then the easy
cop-out is to you know is to your ego to
take over and be like oh yeah they get
to do it you know he's a special kind of
man okay yeah
has it been tough to like date with us
with these types of like to be such an
adventure I feel like that dating would
feel like a anchor kind of well so men
are attracted to the adventure and the
fact that you are adventurous but I just
want you to stop the adventure once
they're with you hmm
they're attracted to you but because
you're adventurous but they that's the
very thing they don't want oh that's
interesting so yeah it's like they want
you to be adventurous but just
adventurous right there for them yeah
they like the flavor of it but not the
activity they want to be the adventure I
think so
maybe not Sandman make fire right yeah I
guess dude there's some guy who just got
busted for arson I saw yesterday so who
knows what they're doing with it now you
know but yeah I just wonder like does it
you know cuz it feels like a very
romantic thing that's why I guess I'm
curious about some of this like going
off to sea you know it has this kind of
romantic connotation you know kind of so
so when I yeah when I meet somebody I
think of what you're a mermaid and I go
yeah but moments need rocks yeah you
know I need to come out Beach beat my
butt it's the caged bird thing you can't
keep the bird in the cage you gotta let
it go but the irony is that so as a
captain I'd go off on boats all the time
sometimes they'd even live on them
running them
and so I really didn't sleep in the same
bed for many weeks in the stretch and
this project has grounded me BR in a
difference oh this is more grounding
yeah because I have a routine and I need
to stick to it to get optimum
performance yeah in big part of that is
sleep and sleeping well where do you
feel like a lot of your desire to like
go into achieve and to do and to like to
just venture like what is that what is
that do you think it comes from a place
you think that that's just kind of a
destined predestined sort of thing I've
always loved boats as a passport to
other things and I think that's why
people own boats so you might go down to
Marina del Rey and there's packed with
boats that don't move but people won't
sell them and they don't sell them
because it's the dream the idea the the
the passport is the best word where they
could literally cast off their life and
go off around the world and then so
that's the it embodies that and I've
loved boats for that and every kind of
boat because they they take you places
it's another life is it a goal do you
feel like like what is your given
ultimate goal I mean I know like
obviously you know traversing what is it
is called traversing the Pacific
Crossing is crossing the Pacific is that
like after that will it be I mean I
guess there's more oceans I I love
writing in fact sometimes I think am I
doing this just circum write about it
right um that that thing of being
writing every day and taking people with
me if I don't do that I feel the whole
thing is pointless but I think when I
wrote the Atlantic I realized that this
really captured people's imagination you
say I'm gonna row and then I'm gonna row
the Atlantic and it's like people know
walking but walking to Mongolia I mean
that's the thing it's just like wow and
then they start thinking well I
technically could walk to Mongolia or
rode the Pacific what am I doing with my
life
yeah I know yet inspires people to think
kind of what they could do yeah and a
lot of women come up to me after talks
and say how do I get your courage how do
I do that thing that I want to do where
does it come from how do I bottle it and
you in that right there do you think
that answer is because sometimes I
wonder if some things are just in in a
person
or if it's actually you know something
that they go do does that make any sense
kind of like as a one-off thing no or if
something like is that is the desire or
the want to do that to to do something
unique is that like an idea that you
could or do you feel like no matter what
you're gonna that's something in you and
you're gonna fight you have to find a
way to let that out of you somehow in
the world you know yeah I think I have a
reach point now I have to row the
Pacific right the idea seeded in 2012 I
wrote the Atlantic and I knew I wasn't
done within hours I I knew I'd be back
doing it again doing it was something is
it something to prove no so I wrote the
Atlantic and I I could have loved it but
now I was bound with this this
relationship problem with my growing
partner we did not get on you did it no
I mean we no farther than this for 74
days I think it's a [ __ ] and I know
about it
really yeah I'll tell you this story
then so what happened to me one time was
I got it caught in this bass fishing
tournament right and so Randy Moss is a
famous he was a famous still as a famous
athlete in America right and maybe other
places but they had a fishing tournament
I've never told this to a woman and
that's him right there
he's african-american gentleman and he's
from South Carolina I think or Georgia
maybe but um he had a fishing tournament
and he invited me to be in the fishing
tournament so I get into a bass boat
dude and I didn't grow up fishing really
think that like my grandfather used to
kill catfish but really just because he
didn't want to spend time around my
grandmother I think and so anyway I go
out on a bass boat I think we're gonna
be out there just for a little while I
stayed up all night the night before at
this party that a big party the night
before it's like a whole weekend that
they did it was in Lake Minnetonka
Minnesota so next year I'll get on this
bass boat in the morning they tell me
have to be on the boat for six hours Wow
I thought it's gonna be out there for
like 40 minutes he's from West Virginia
Randy amazing athlete who's a really
really neat man and great fisherman too
so anyway I have to go to the bathroom
like I have to go number two where I got
to take a dump or [ __ ] whatever they
call it you know what they call it in
Britain what do they call it yeah
going to the dawn of the lunar the loo
for a while pop to the loo yeah pop to
the loo for sure oh man Malou if I have
to you know and if it's really coming on
quit but anyhow so I have to go to the
bathroom and I'm like I need to go to
the bathroom like oldest pee over the
side of the boat and now I'm too
embarrassed to tell these guys that I
have to do more than pee right right so
basically I end up telling them like I'm
gonna go for like a swim for a second
right what are you talking about like
everybody's in fishing clothes like
everybody's fasters bait like it's a
really small just a flat boat and there
you're like I'm going swimming so
literally they're like well we're not
stopping the boats you know I'm in like
an argument with these guys right so
then I had to hang off the side of this
boat and perform excrement at the same
time so like undid us
yes I'm it sheared arrest man you know
like definitely the Coast Guard would
have pulled us over
ya know whales would have shown up to
watch but it anyway was just an alarming
moment I think that's where the
expression scared the [ __ ] out of you
I've never sit that close to a
gas-powered motor in my entire life as I
had that day literally hanging onto the
side of the boat and it's hard to clench
your muscles up top and relax in there
at the you know what about a bucket did
that occur to you it didn't cause I
didn't know these guys went off like I
had to hide my body in the water like
that was the thing oh I was hanging off
in the water oh so my body's in the
water did you not explain after the fact
i I they got the pay they figured it out
right now did they laughs yeah yeah we
all had a good laugh thankfully yes man
they're like wanting you to say
something like I was just ashamed I
guess are embarrassed you know but but
anyway so that's why when you're in the
two-person and someone has to go to the
bathroom what are they do they go down
below
no they just take the bucket and go on
deck so you always you try and do it
while the other person's sleeping but
still do you really yeah Wow we're not
in the same cabin but you're on deck
they're in the cabin but and especially
if you're not getting along with each
other what's that like cuz I feel like
you know that's kind of it's not
embarrassing but it's like you know it's
a thing that you know we all kind of
keep that hidden as humans you know
especially is like you know Eastern
European humans are white you know or
people Americans whatever Brit
it's like we're kind of posh in that
sense about like bathroom stuff is that
weird
well we got over a really quick we got
naked and then there was a it was
practical to be naked and then you
forget you're naked that's the other
thing you've got to remember to put
clothes on really yeah
when that coast guard came by and I was
like oh [ __ ] you know grab something and
right you forget because it's
comfortable and yeah and you forget you
know new normal the normal is naked and
clothes and you put clothes on they feel
like itchy and confining so kg yeah and
if you've got a bit of salt and skin
that's gritty but I quite like that
actually yeah yeah it doesn't bother me
good which is a good thing right if a
man took you on a sailboat would that be
like is that a romantic endeavor to you
or no no because that's what that's what
I do for work that's work and it's funny
cuz my but if a man took you to a
regular cubicle in an office building is
that romantic depends what we didn't
that's what I'm talking about our past
the old whales showing up all of a
sudden a but but I race or I say all
really fast boats they usually
million-dollar-plus
and so friends have boats you know they
go yeah do you want to come out for a
day and I'm like no you know you you
have a Ford Fiesta and I sell Ferraris
and get paid for it and it's really hard
for my friends to understand that it's
going we'll have a nice day out we go
swimming have a picnic I'm like that's
my worst nightmare yeah yeah that's like
someone having a picnic in the office
your cubicle on Sunday on a Sunday
exactly do you um even though it's the
best office obviously yeah with a great
view you know yeah so you can't complain
but still it's like no that's what I did
for what do you miss the most when
you're gone like when you get back is it
the company of soft furnishings really
yeah because the seat is hard and the
deck is hard and you lie in the cabin
and cuz it's all fiberglass so I made it
a five carbon carbon no way yes my new
votes gonna be ourselves over yeah so
the sofa is an amazing invention and
lying on it great and do you not getting
up and do you have like decisions like
the fridge yeah just you marvel at
modern technology you go to the fridge I
open it there's things in it
but then you need somebody to put things
in it and yeah so actually to answer the
question I trained mind my mind a bit by
going to the float tank you know that
was big in the 70s these sensory
deprivation tanks its fill of up some
salts and it's a closed space at Nam I
think even today I think they did
somebody know that was water torture
waterboarding Flugtag these salts and
you're basically alone with your mind
and the minute you lie down your body
disappears like you're not you are a
mind in a box and so you've got to get
used to that the dark that clicks
Siegfried and Roy it's like you're on
like a David Copperfield or something
yeah and then it's amazing the journeys
your mind goes on in that era nah
sometimes it just drops down into
breathing and that breathing becomes a
really calm thing so that's that's been
really good for mental training do you
relax overall we're out on the water or
is it tense mm-hmm and there are moments
relaxing no it's tense that's dense is
it tense from the moment you start or is
it tense when the water gets a certain
way well you have to be able to enjoy it
I go out you know I'm going days months
whatever so you need to be switched on
to okay this is beautiful moment more
things are going great and and have
those micro celebrations because I might
not succeed 18 people have tried and
only two succeeded so every step of this
project I have to celebrate the
milestones you know we're having a chat
that's a your amaz dad oh that's
exciting if you have a book to that's
about it's 50 what is it 50 things to do
on the water 50 water adventures to do
before you die and you've done a few of
them you use mentioned the cage diving
yes and yeah fishing isn't there fishing
is there almost drowned one time fishing
that's not in their wild swimming naked
is in there which you know he's not too
far from drowning in and then so the
premise of the book was to find the best
place in the world if you were to do
whitewater rafting only once where would
you do it where would you do it well not
the Grand Canyon surprisingly they're
more challenging rap rapids and
beautiful sceneries down in Patagonia in
in Chile yeah the food lathy River and
the great thing about writing a book was
after I wrote it I went and did a lot of
them like was a lot of it was a pot it
was it was a gift to free holidays it
was great oh wow you'd think you would
do them before you wrote the book but
the doesn't how it happened oh yeah
that's not the way it works these days
what was your favorite one do you have a
favorite of one that you've done of
their 50 things to do the one I'd like
to do which isn't par with what I'm
doing right now is I'd like to learn to
row a gondola and Venice and you can
there's one organization called Viva
Vogel of vaanga which is which is about
preserving that tradition of wooden
boats going up because it's Bing it's
being surpassed now by zippy little
powerboat and can you imagine being the
gondolier as a woman and not an Italian
I know and there's a whole you know like
taxi driver
oh yeah the door it's yeah it's a dark
little under seedy underworld no it's
it's there's 500 licenses.only and they
get handed down from generations and
super to get into definitely not you
know as a non Italian on as male well
but do you think that that's cool though
it's almost like cool to keep it like
that there like the tradition of it you
know I think so but if you and it's not
easy there you can fall in so you learn
on a botella which is a as a work boat
winter when you come put like your
desire do you think it's a competent do
you think you compete against the ocean
do you think you compete against I can't
do this do you think a woman's never
done this like is it what is your
competition like what is your why am i
doing it yes like yeah but why it more
of like a level of like I think that to
be the first woman is just a cherry on
the icing and I think if I could do it
completely self-funded and tell no one
and just go and do it that would be my
first choice and then it wouldn't be
about performing for anyone there be no
not for sponsors or anything yeah I mean
why why do humans do what we do right
it's the great fascination I think for
for this project in particular and for
me it's about channeling and channeling
forces that we all have so I mean my
support psychologist says that people
are motivated by pain and humiliation
and probably
and we all have pain and we've all been
through different degrees of humiliation
now if you took all of that and go okay
[ __ ] you all [ __ ] what happened I'm
gonna channel that and I mean so
directly into that one thing and give it
everything I've got
yeah is it hard as you as you continue
to go on and like you know it's funny I
noticed this how we're just talking
about this on the podcast this week on
the regular episode where like I find as
like our podcast gets more listeners and
like you know just things get busier and
have a producer and like a you know a
couple producer like I start to be like
well how do I keep it from getting away
from whatever my original goals are but
my original purpose you know do you feel
like that does that ever happen to you
like even in in rowing because I just
think is it's a fascinating thing that
happens kind of in the world you know
it's like it's like my body started to
paint my buffer and painted this picture
of this is Chris Farley okay okay just a
lot of people think it's me or Donald
Trump and I don't want to us okay
I mean I've definitely had some nights I
woke up looking like that and I actually
once met a girl that looked like that
and I didn't I didn't sleep with that
girl so just for the record yes
definitely for the record dude even
though she thinks we you know whatever
but it's a good concern you know like
how do you stay true to yeah yeah and
I'm curious because with your thing that
is something you gotta well this year I
went crowdfunded last year I had a
sponsor and this year we parted ways for
on amicable terms and I was like how do
I keep going I've been a year and a half
of my life training I've got fat to San
Francisco you know this has become my
world and I I put it out there I wrote a
blog and said look dear world this is
what's happened and I have to keep going
and these the reasons why I'm no longer
with this sponsor but you know and the
boat that I have I thought it was the
right boat but actually it's not key to
my success and I said I've got the
couple of people who've donated money
and I call them my believers and I
started I'm on patreon oh good I call
this community my believers good and the
most powerful thing wasn't the money so
the money is now enough
I could keep going but once I've been
patreon funded so if you believe it
thank you
yeah it's the same thing that happened
here we wouldn't have had our studio for
more for patreon yeah so I call them
believers because every time somebody
signed up it was like they stepped into
an imaginary room in my life and said I
believe in you keep going I'm with you
and I was just you know charged by that
yeah and now it's gathering momentum and
there are more people and their network
is amazing so when I wrote down the
coast I stayed with a friend of the
believer and and then other believers
connected me with the media and and
that's probably how we met yeah actually
yeah yeah well we had a Tom grey block
Thomas fair who was one of our first
sponsor ever and who inspired me to like
get out of my doing the podcast out of
my apartment and be brave enough to take
the next step and he gave a sponsorship
money so he's your first believe my
first believer yeah he was like here's a
thousand bucks to give you a thousand
bucks this month you know just to help
you know and he's like you can do it and
I was like I don't think I can do it I
wanted to take his thousand and just go
to the bank and never do the podcast
yeah but that's where I'm from it's from
the plate I'm from the place where it's
like man I made a thousand bucks dude
you know I'm saying enough just give two
hundred of this to the guy who works at
the graveyard I'm spend the other 800 a
party and I'll see you guys in because
it's given with such trust and it's such
a promise of right you know I believe in
your potential I got was it and it was
that extra thing that came along with it
that like he's like look I've been where
you been and and I can see where you can
go and so I'm gonna believe in you know
and it's magnificent because I wouldn't
have done that without his support but
here I am meeting you but he was who
reached out he's like hey you should
talk to this woman and we haven't even
met she's doing something incredible
time I know right oh really no okay
that's amazing but he's like she's doing
something very unique and it would be a
neat conversation and it has been but
it's not a new thing people back in
people you know in fact on the way down
when I wrote down I was listening to
endeavor you know the Shackleton story
where they barely survived and they had
to row from Elephant Island down in
Antarctica and I I learned through
listening to his book on on podcast
inaudible that he was crowdfunded back
in the nine early 19th century
people sent him money from all around
the world I mean literally the money in
an envelope
well Shackleton oh yeah I'm sure he had
some private you know sirs of this and
that who wrote big numbers but he was
people backed well even like Columbus
and those guys like people were just
like yeah here's some money good luck
out there you know good luck finding the
City of Gold it's like imagine if you
put that nowadays you went some people
want to go look for the lost city of
gold that would actually be the best go
fund me ever yeah but people would want
to be part of it yeah
can you you're fine you're like you're
five bucks will help put man on the moon
you like yeah five bucks yeah oh man on
the moon you know you into it and so
that okay I'm crossing an ocean that's a
little different but it's a little bit
like that it's fascinating and so I mean
if you could do the whole thing
people-powered Wow yeah just it would be
then you create you get so creative it's
like right it doesn't makes you more
creative cuz it makes you feel like you
have support yeah and once you have the
support you're not thinking about those
types of things but you also start
thinking of ways to give back but in
your own way yes not by turning up to be
in an appearance but by in my way
writing or making art or whatever yes
you know in your case making you know
having good conversations
yeah good conversations with uh with
with strange people strange people yeah
strange like people but no even you
having this conversation right now it
makes me think that I should go look
through the patreon sand-like find ones
that I can donate to or things that we
can do like and we think about that all
the time you know like we started doing
thing for single moms we always did we
talked about that on here a lot but
we're gonna start doing a thing for like
cleaning ladies we're gonna do like a
surprise game show in a hood in the
hotel room for the cleaning lady who
comes in like she's not gonna know that
there's like hidden cameras and stuff
and then like it was gonna be an
announcement in the room and she's gonna
have like so much time to find money
that's hidden in the room but then
she'll be messing up the room which she
then is gonna have to clean up that's
twisted
it is but it'll be like a nice well you
know it'll be like a nice fun way and
we'll think of like some way to like
make it cue to make it sweet to her you
know like so it's but it's like you know
where it's like oh you're just doing
your job but then now suddenly you can
make some extra money and it's like a
fun thing you know there used to be this
TV showing that I loved and they would
take people on to doing ordinary jobs
and mess with them like a pizza delivery
guy and they'd go here's
large
some money if you can throw those pizzas
into the open windows and then they
would take say your favorite teddy or
your favorite shoes who favorite
armchair and then go and dangle it by
helicopter over the Thames going how
much is it and sometimes drop it anyway
oh it's just evil the great viewing yeah
yes um they just killed a pizza guy
first car the other day so that's like
an American that's real life yeah but a
couple guys ordered a pizza and they
shot the guy and it went Nate it um we
have other questions that called it
sorry to take it there sorry this went
dark for a minute yeah you know when I
can't communicate with women sometimes
at my keys see they run away yeah
something wrong with me she's still here
yeah do you have any safety preparations
for when you get to the edge of the
earth you just slide off and that is the
white is it Eddie Bravo I've ever seen
in life that's what am i that sort of
her Regulus he's not but he that's
through the family right yep that's
through the live race fan line people
can submit video questions yeah what are
you gonna are you well I used to believe
in a flat earth society it's really
fascinated by this group of people got
flat so we've had we've had one of the
biggest rioters of them on here what
have you been to the you know the Space
Museum and in Florida and you look at
these things you go really that when in
space made out of you know tinfoil oh
it's horrible and cotton wool oh it's a
Ford Festiva how did that get up there
yeah how did it even get through the
stratosphere not burn up into you know
just like melted part of whatever yeah I
don't like it looks like that thing
couldn't make it through two summers in
Birmingham Alabama
you know it's barely holding up in the
museum it's really true though it's like
that is a good case for the flat you
know and the whole thing was clearly
played faked in Hollywood no one man has
been on the moon what's up with the
scene with the things that they could do
I'm not I couldn't I wouldn't be
surprised if that could have happened
for sure but did you add were you
actually a flat earther at some point I
mean I've been tongue-in-cheek but right
buddy but you considered and even you
though being out on the water that much
well it is it is trippy because you
can't see you can
see 24 miles on a good day okay and
that's because the earth is round you
know you lose the visibility and so yeah
you know some days there it's like
curtains opened and you can see miles
and then other days it's really close
mmm just the atmosphere changes and so
we're quite trapped in by the clouds
really and then and then when it breaks
open it's like this huge release strange
and so some days you can see further and
some days you can't do you think that's
because you're going like on a certain
little moment in the earth where it's
like a little flattering little bump
no it's just um it's just conditions
it's it's the density of the air it's
the clouds how low they are how high
they are but there are moments we feel
like this could be flat this I could see
why people could think this could be
flat yeah so my rowing partner in the
Atlantic had never flown to America and
he's gonna row there well I learned this
halfway and I was like oh my god you
must feel like Christopher Columbus
discovering a new world you have
actually no concept of distance yeah
because if you've been in a plane say to
Japan and in quarters for 12 hours and
so if you row it then you can go okay
you you've got the time zones you can
you can picture in your mind but if you
hadn't flown it then it could feel
endless yeah and daunting and scary and
you just shut down and go Kevin yeah
their days were you recite I'm going in
the cab and leave me alone for a few
days no no I mean I've got to a point
now so I'm designing a new boat and with
this new bow potentially I could
challenge the men's record really and
that's really exciting so now we're now
we're getting it suddenly we've got like
to optimize so that's one of the things
that you'd like to do you'd like a
chance of men's record
well it's if possible okay I'd like to
see anybody beat the French for any
reason no I support that I mean getting
getting across full stop getting across
alive is the main priority on land to
land not getting towed yeah and being
the first woman is is the cherry but
actually beating the men's would be far
more significant do you think like men
feel like it's tough to like like say if
a man is a track to do you like it there
yet it stuff like that makes them
nervous that probably having a woman am
i intimidating I don't know I don't feel
like you are but I think it definitely
could be I feel like if things got like
you know
if we weren't like gonna on a boat or
like even in just like a like even if we
were in the shower together and like
there was an earthquake I feel like
things could get really really you would
definitely be the captain and I would
definitely like the third mate I think
the thing that's intimidating is I don't
need a man right you know that's the
that's the thing the male done right the
resistance playing inside of a man's
head where it's like we want to be the
one to be able to help a woman through
the storm I guess
yeah provides a captain a caretaker and
not have to have the woman and keep fend
off the bears you know
yeah or sharks yeah that's so there's
biggest turnoff for me is taking a man
on a boat watching him plunder around
and be useless right I think that's just
you know I just you can't do stuff so
that men can feel of use have you ever
done that no I never did you wouldn't I
just don't take him out in a boat
because it's like I'll see another side
of you and I just instantly I would be
literally hammering a point to the boat
but I'd bring a blindfold out one 4x4
and a hammer and a nail but if you don't
even try and you just sit there with a
nice bottle of wine and offered me sips
that's fine but don't even try right now
but don't be that crazy guy that's out
there yeah I don't go oh what can I do
oh that's so on a track to starboard
like what the [ __ ] you talking about hey
you know what I'm saying we haven't even
done we haven't even left yet
we're still in the car we're still in
the uber on the way to the beach but if
I go on a guy's boat then I just you
know I
you're the captain you're the master
you're the but you run the ship I'm just
gonna be a passenger yeah
and I'm good at switching that off you
are yeah just be the passenger yeah it's
a competent right if they're not
competent then I get it all yeah but
it's tricky working in my world because
my very good man
yeah I've a 200-ton captain's license I
could basically drive a cross-channel
ferry and most of my peers are
50-something year-old men and yeah so
you've like Danica Patrick sometimes
anymore way like just that like she kind
of was in when it went into a feel that
was like predominantly man or like you
know it's kind of this old sort of boys
club
I mean you're fighting the tide and so
predominately I run boats by myself yeah
and then higher boys to help me does it
ever feel kind of empowering a little
bit if it's slightly wrong I need help
doing stuff hey Antonio do you name them
all Antonio it sounds like something we
have a couple more questions that came
in Nick can you find something else
pretty neat yes sir
Thanks book whatever you're in the
middle of the room you know you're at
the bottom of the barrel of your energy
and you're feeling exhausted order some
of the mental tricks that you use you
know how do you tap into that Navy SEAL
mindset whatever you got knowing as you
left what do you do what do you tell
yourself to push through those plateaus
and you know overcome those boundaries
Thanks looking forward to ship yeah when
you're at that when you're at that
moment what do you do I think the best
thing is to laugh really but you
actually remember that like I know we
say we do think but do you do that yeah
I remind myself that I chose to be there
oh my god chose to be there you idiot
you know and that breaks the seal on
that you know downward spiral have you
ever been hit by lightning or not
no but I've had lightning crack the
water right by a boat and I did think
that would Batman bus right on my bag it
would scare me something I was really
annoyed with myself because on that
particular trip I'd looked at buying a
rescue beacon like the week before this
was a paid delivery that I was with the
owner was down below I taught him to
navigate yesterday he was Jewish and a
cardiovascular surgeon to his sharp
right but he was navigating now having
learnt yesterday oh right and and he's
saying he can do it he's doing it you
know we're one mile from a reef and we
this is off Long Island you know those
storms that come rolling off the New
York Center not surprised and yeah it
was just wicked lightening around and
the boats almost lifting off it's being
almost airborne and I'm just annoyed
with myself going oh you're gonna die
because of that you didn't spend 800
bucks last week idiot you know because
that instrument would have what diverted
the yeah rescue people Oh a larger
rescue peewee
got saved we were not going to get saved
at that point if I didn't drive the boat
in a certain way and he didn't keep us
off the reef we were in very very bad
trouble
ones that can shoot the thing the flare
says you know a kid has started a forest
fire with one of those actually and that
kid is still they don't know who he is
and I'm not gonna say his name but he
don't always go off oh this one went off
dude yeah
this one went off oh yes we blowed about
probably I would say 6,000 trees is dude
oh wow took care of some acres boy you
know I'm saying this guy definitely
won't you don't [ __ ] with even matches
he won't even blow out a birthday cake
anymore he's that weary of it he's been
burned [ __ ] oh dude he didn't how old
he is he does not even know how old he
is just a sheer most guys go through a
little arsenic phase of trying to burn
stuff oh I think I said other did I
threw about a wine bottle off of an
interstate off of a bridge over an
interstate once and uh how did that work
out it hit a Buick or a Crown Victoria
so but so that was like my arson phase
no actual fire but just angry you know
just like angry with a [ __ ]
confession for the day dude I was in
Atlanta drank half of the bottle and
this threw that bastard I do not do this
at home and we reassure this is a long
time ago and this is before people were
doing that kind of stuff
now everybody's doing that kind of stuff
well that's why they have fencing up on
yeah bridges to avoid you dude is that
aggressive recycling every site that's
really what it is what was the question
that just came in I even forgot what it
was well wet what's your net Navy SEAL
oh yeah so what is your mindset when you
get down at that point
yeah you well you just either just deal
with it you know you've got the
experience to get yourself out of this
pickle you got yourself in are things
ever so bad you're just like ah [ __ ] it
I'm gonna go take a nap downstairs
sometimes that is the best solution yeah
sometimes
um just sleeping and stopping is resets
everything like the other day I was
fighting my way off the coast and in a
training row and I threw out the anchor
and I was like I just need to stop
rowing and then everything will be good
and I spoke to her friend who didn't
have any clue that I was on anchor and I
was going through this
and you said something or other value no
you're really great we're gonna help you
do this and that just lifted my spirits
well that's good that was really good
it's amazing what human connection can
do sometimes huh yes when you get out
there that can you call your mom or what
can you do yes the satellite phones are
still pretty primitive so you have a
satellite phone it's like a brick you
you call it you spend the first ten
dollars going hello hello can you hear
me oh that's so much fun and then senior
said you know but you have there's a
text device now so you can send text
messages like on a mobile phone but the
problem with that is you have to retrain
people because you can't just send a
text followed by another text because
that will you know it's gonna go a
satellite that will block me for 24
hours and if you've got a text for a
hundred and sixty characters use them
you know if I'm gonna see receive one
text not a yeah don't write good
progress that's really irritating Wow
indeed is it kind of night is that
what's that like being so connecting it
so it's hard to get unconnected now
isn't it
right yeah I'd rather not take a phone
in many ways but it's so hard for us to
get disconnected isn't it still be and
the more money you take the more
sponsorship you have the more
connectivity they want yes they want
they want a live stream yeah you know
they want to see me get undressed and go
everyday and who is this porn blurring
on that Pacific by the way is cold I'll
be wearing is it really yeah it's not
it's not Alaska cold but it's between
Alaska and Hawaii so it's temperate yeah
they'll be cold days and warm days and I
predominately won't what kind of
sunscreen you wear like SPF was 650 I
put 50 on my face I drink the SPF
milkshakes I'm like you must have a
cover up 1,000 yeah dude also I would
not only what I wear a sunscreen I would
also go like this a lot of times make
that it is so hot yeah wear a big hat
what kind of birds you see out there
vultures ever buzzards other sea birds
and they live on the sea really yeah and
so there's ones that look like
pterodactyls and there's a lot of those
I've ever seen a pelican oh there's tons
of them around that's cool
that's my state bird I saw a lot of
albatross in the southern ocean
oh really are amazing I don't like
they're like giant super
seagulls yeah and when there's not much
wind it's like watching a Christmas your
Thanksgiving turkey trying to take off
yeah
splosh and then they go it wasn't me it
wasn't me fail
they're like the Greyhound bus of
seagulls yeah they're basically this big
huge [ __ ] air shrimp look can we
another question please hey what's up vo
long time fan so actually be rate of
infection because I just went kayaking
this weekend in San Juan ours officer I
sorts in killer whales so some gray
whales but now now that I got the buzz
don't want to go kayaking on my guy is
out with that oh the guys that he cooked
me around and he do everything about the
currents and where to go so my question
for leader is like is this something
that needn't be living with a while and
between beautif we come here to pick up
put it quickly
yeah like can that guy just get in a
vessel like yours would he if he headed
out what do you have a chance
um some chance a percentage chance I
mean knowing the water is really helpful
it's like you could fly plane right but
air currents and weather systems will
mean that you probably survive better
mmm if not just survive knowing that
because it's not just there's so much
more going on on top of the water right
well actually also underwater so the the
big revelation for me in rowing now
rather than sailing is how much the
topography under water makes a
difference like all of these canyons
yeah and underwater mountains had create
current patterns and ripples and stuff
that I feel it's not phenomenal so the
air the water is just wet air really
yeah I guess deep space like down space
do you ever feel like the water is the
world and that the air is the I think
it's two layers so when I get into clean
the water and I discover this whole like
ecosystem under the under the underneath
the surface I do think there's like the
land layer and then there's the ocean
layer and we as humans are only capable
of going so far in Earth
there's so much more and there's no
light so the creatures down here have no
color scary a bit and they they look so
prehistoric and gnarly like there's one
chapter in my book where you can go in a
submarine as a as a passenger and they
go down 600 feet to where there are
creatures with no name oh so every time
they go down they see something I hadn't
even seen you know see diagnosed
prescribed as species that are unwritten
off the textbooks and so there is so I
think this is the final frontier for
discovery you know we've got air pretty
mad much mapped we're big in space but
the sea okay some some was it James
Cameron went down to the Marianas Trench
but that's it there's all of this other
stuff this underwater well canyons and
trenches does that scare you at all you
think I think it's really exciting oh I
have my excitement yeah I'll be like
down there driving yeah well what is it
stuff I feel like if I had to go across
the ocean it would have to be with
somebody like you because you seem like
have a really good disposition like what
makes you like when do you when do you
lose it you know like when do you
[ __ ] lose it oh really only because
of things I've done yeah so I didn't
listen to myself I knew I shouldn't go
out today and I knew the wind was gonna
switch and I just went anyway and that's
when I get annoyed it's not because of
anything that happens like you're a
perfectionist do you think not really
it's just I wanted I should know better
my better judgment it's like if you yeah
you know like you yeah but I knew you
should get up in the morning at set now
and you didn't you know you get annoyed
with yourself because now you've screwed
up your whole day yeah you got syrup all
in your bed could you eat in there I
wouldn't get that far but like yeah I
went out to the first time I went to try
and do this fair alone record I told the
meteor I was going so they made it this
huge deal oh and then the day came in
the marine layer which is this fog that
gets sucked in because desert heats up
well yeah my grandfather was a cigarette
smoker so I know what you're talking
about
senior marine layer so 6:00 in the
morning I knew it was a bust
now what do you do take a normal day I
just would have gone okay will this land
this
is now in I should not go out there but
you did it anyway I did it anyway
because all of the you know the
photographer was booked and there was
gonna be this big shebang and ended up
being in the front and back the San
Francisco Chronicle not a disaster I'll
just do it sort of so I go under the
Golden Gate Bridge and I go okay just
reset your mind you're going for a row
it'll be fine you'll learn things so I
go out there and they check in about
3:00 in the afternoon going how's it
going and quite clearly I'm not getting
off the coast because the marine layer
is pressing me on the coast so you just
hop they're rowing against the marine
layer rowing against so the marine layer
has this wind funnel and comes on it and
I got stuck in that and I couldn't bust
through it so I'm coming back through
the gate and I'm really annoyed with
myself you know why did you do it why
did you try and trying to put myself
back together the humiliation of it I
had openly allowed myself to be
humiliated and I get back to the dock
and there's a family that's about
pounced on me like with young children
excited yet excited and they looked like
they've come down to see me in and I'm
in no state to really meet and greet and
I barely tied up the boat and already on
me and it turns out that they've seen me
in the paper and the grandmother had
told this six-year-old and the
six-year-old is like I got to see this
and this child looked at me like I was a
Disney Princess mmm
and inside I'm going home and hands me
this pink note and this pink note I open
it up and it says I admire you for
trying mmm you'll do it next time
and I just melted oh wow and it's like
this is why this is confirmation of why
I do what I do is like I possibly
changed the life direction of that
six-year-old girl on that day right
I blew open the world of possibility
yeah yeah and there she confirmed for me
that it was worth it yeah like I've gone
out there I'd done something that was
usually vulnerable I had failed I'd
failed publicly and I'd come back in and
some six-year-old with glowing eyes
tells you that you you admired you for
try yeah yeah yeah and it keeps your
heart pumping so yeah you know it's so
true it's so true to you know just the
the to know and the victory is in trying
like that's one thing that I've realized
over the years like the victories in
trying like
few people achieve you know like
penultimate like successes and things
you know and there's so few spaces for
that too
you know like there's only one person's
gonna be like a Richard Pryor you know
in my world in my comedy world only one
person is gonna be you know Captain Ahab
or who's the lady from with the spangled
off or the mermaid Little Mermaid era
Gale you know only one person but that
it erielle yes sorry I don't know who
era Gale is you made it up I would go I
rolled with it it was sounded good but
it's like maybe that's her full name and
I don't know it because I'm not American
and you know you just created something
that oh dude we got the car right
outside of Disneyworld once yeah so like
but yeah it's like but trying is the
thing yeah I mean that's the that's the
fun look at you now like that then I
Thomas gave you a thousand bucks yeah
and you could have just gone and done
nothing with it or got yeah and you gave
it a go and that is actually huge
yeah any the thing is it but if it yen
without somebody making you feel like
you can try like without him telling me
that I don't make that leap you know I
don't make that but you cared I'm gonna
get us to do I could write but I don't
know if I do I don't I don't I don't I
don't know if I do yeah you know so it
is it's instrumental then like wow we
need that's why we need we need each
other we can help you Jess yes we can
help you that is I'd say the scariest
part of like this whole project was that
point where you go I'm gonna say out
loud like remember do you remember that
day when you go I'm gonna do this
podcast okay you know and you you start
telling people gauging their reactions
in you're scared that people are gonna
go no shut that down like that's a bad
idea get out of its face but then it's
sort of slightly pervert and then you go
okay okay I'm committed I'm actually
gonna do it I bought quipment you know
yeah and then that's the beginning and
then in a way that's scarier and people
would say when you depart Japan isn't
that terrifying I go no it's gonna be a
blessed relief I'd be like yeah thank
God all this work all this training I
just gonna leave now
ya know so you know what it's so funny
that's yeah everything else is
doing it yes at that point you're doing
it but it's the trying in the end that
was the most fun - yeah like this is
great like it's really neat to learn
about you know your universe and you
know I'll be able to lay in bed at night
or you know in in a safe man or not like
look I'm talking about with my hands
tied behind my head nothing lewd yeah
and I'm also I think seven days clean
for masturbation right now six days
clean but that's not a saucing thing
it's like fasting for your hands
basically did you get tendinitis is haha
I just don't have the healthiest way
like I just started like not doing it
well over the not bad I was still
functional I just like yeah like I just
I've done it enough so I don't want to
master ready to boy like I didn't have a
problem but I didn't I was just doing it
out of habit then I was out of like oh
I'm gonna do like a sexual enjoyment
here it ain't part of your daily routine
no it became part of my like by daily
routine well I
yeah every yeah but yeah daily yeah I
just want to say I wasn't somebody who
was like running around pulling off the
side of the road in math reading I never
had a problem then I guess that's a
problem earlier this year I ran out of
testosterone I trained to the point
where I depleted my testosterone and now
I could you know belly motivate to get
up in the morning it's a really useful
thing that's testosterone I heard you
mention HGH in here and I didn't ask
about it but it was so did you start do
you have any good injection no no no of
course not
but one day I did test 200 in high
school I couldn't fit into a navicomp B
shirt that's for damn sure dude but one
day I ran out of olive oil
so I started cooking with butter and I
came back seriously are you serious it
turns out that you need some cholesterol
to make testosterone yeah and yeah
cooking with butter brought it all back
well I had this conversation when you
nutrition so you guys well how do you
know and I go cuz I'm horny Oh a good
business make me [ __ ] erect
that's for damn sure boy a good biscuit
catching us out of a crackle crackle
bear all [ __ ] I'll talk anything
outside of a Cracker Barrel so yes I'm
not sure that you could be that horny at
sea if you are putting all of your
effort into throwing because we're all
eating the very thing that makes you
feel that way that makes you
viola Rajan Asst yes so I guess if
you're storm bound for a couple of days
and you start to bounce back you know
the hormone levels rise does the C feel
like a man or a woman does it have like
a male or female vibe to it I like that
question I think I always think of
mother nature right me too and I have a
huge respect for the ocean I'm not
afraid of it but I it's it's force of
power
you ever been out in a way so I fear
I've always not enjoyed swimming even
going out with Jay Mohr and going out
like just in doing that paddleboarding
out in the ocean was fascinating to me
seeing like the seaweed at the top of
the water and realizing oh it's not the
trees yes yeah I thought it's just a
shitty [ __ ] plant I thought I was
just the [ __ ] devil's you know beard
hair that just keeps washing up on the
shore but it is a plant that's just
growing and now we're at the top of a
pretty feet high yeah I'm at the top of
a really weird tree yeah I think you get
scared by the ocean just because it's
not your world like yeah I went into a
really wild forest I'd be on edge going
I don't know what creatures could jump
me yeah and but a nightclub also feels
way more foreign and uncomfortable to me
than the oh that's like a forest with
people who could jump you and Doc Thanks
yeah like damn these trees are on dope
yeah that tree has that's putting glow
sticks in but but to some extent like
the ocean that people behaving weirdly
and nightclub is predictable yeah so
that's a good point yeah I mean if you
spend as much time on the ocean you get
more comfortable with it it's like a
second home it's like there's the land
existence and then there's the sea
existence and I'm almost more complete
out there yeah my life is sorted I know
I'm very strong and decision I make
decisions very quickly in a way I don't
on land like you barely decide what to
wear in the morning you know yeah yeah I
wonder how I'd be out on out on the sea
you know but I think it's fascinating
for everybody to lose sight of shore and
for I mean you imagine me five months by
yourself alone with no sight of anybody
or anything like that's quite
fascinating just alone regardless of the
rowing yeah
and you have that Aquarius well I
haven't I was with somebody else I've
been Eliza with Aberdeen one month by
myself on
Oshin races what are you worried you're
gonna find out about yourself like any
deep dark secrets that you were gonna
that you don't that you don't think you
would like are you gonna get to the
other side and be like a lesbian or you
can just want to be mayor I don't think
so
yeah I think I'll discover the beauty
small beauties and in life and a lot
that you take for God for granted
yeah the one thing when you get back to
see you just have no time for people who
are late and no time for like frivolous
crap
yeah like hurry up with that and don't
stress over this it's just not worth it
you realize the the huge wealth and
health thing well and I love there and
love as well yeah it's important yeah
the value of each other yeah Wow it's
interesting how being alone for that
long can then help you realize the value
of that you know or the value of good
people yeah
because if you filter out everything and
then you send me a text and that's the
only message I guess like a letter yeah
and I open it and and I'm connecting
with you even though I'm like millions
of miles away and it's just a text in
your ordinary day but it has so much
meaning to me you ever get like any like
booty calls out there like you up you
know I mean you're like you're just on a
soft tide out there in the middle of
nowhere and you just get a you up yeah I
think the text that you want to receive
coming called four categories the first
one is information you know you're
there's a big storm coming this way you
know you need to battle down and and be
prepared for it and then the next one is
entertainment
mhm like the best text you could receive
might be I fell asleep last night with
the light on and pair of scissors in my
right hand
yeah I'm you can spend a whole day
thinking about what the hell that meant
or last night went out on date night
with my wife and we went to Italian
place and she had tiramisu yeah and it's
not it's not G it's not here it's not
you're doing great right yeah oh yeah
well done congratulations it's it's
little stories like that that that you
can take they're all just your
imagination run away with ah really
great is it nice to have your
imagination again I feel like you feel
that way
yeah like I told my niece about her
imagination and she's like what is
imagination no yes
at that and she's very imaginative she
didn't know she just I guess I don't
know if they you know if people are even
talking about it anymore
she's like isn't it you know she like
looked at my phone I'm like no it's not
your phone it's like a well that's the
benefit books over TV because in a book
you fill in everything and is being by
yourself out there I bet your brain just
like sprouts new [ __ ] for aliens
yeah how about your brain doesn't
[ __ ] can relax you come up with more
crazy things to do they that's the
problem
oh that's so while so after I wrote a
Pacific I'm actually gonna reenact it on
sand dunes in the Nevada desert no you
know yeah okay yeah really yeah so I
I've done this before
so I studied fine art and then after I
sailed across the Atlantic in the race I
went and reenacted the crossing outside
to take Britain Gallery in London as a
performance artwork so I I was on my
boat beached basically out of the water
for a month without getting off eating
the same food mmm in the middle of
London which was harder to achieve than
getting the boat to America because I
had to get permission from mi6 and real
and at night did like homeless people
come by and just cried sake already got
you did yeah people you know drunk
people spilling out the pub would shout
lewd things really yeah we see it was
one of the summers of the World Cup and
football so I was really lonely while
everyone was watching football but I had
amazing conversations with people and I
actually no I never thought so lonely as
I did stuck on that boat in London Wow
then I I never feel that in the ocean
mmm because I have incredible scenery
and have wild life and yeah yeah I have
a text machine so I can send text I love
it yeah it's fascinating hum any other
good question would have put one more
through Necker we kind of answered them
all through the flow of the conversation
the ones that were I thought were good
was fascinating so Leah did what about
the ones that were bad no no I don't
mean to go there but are there some bad
ones there's there's one for sure do we
wanna um yeah I mean if we can always
take this part out if it's too bad
I haven't her all these okay here's uh
probably the worst a Theo Nia it's a
Lucas here from Ottawa Canada they don't
start here not come to Troy
looking forward to seeing it but
regardless I'm just hanging out here got
some chicken in the oven I just had a
long weekend of kicking down doors to
take it down fours but questions for you
with the rowing do you find that with
the strength you obviously have your
forms and your biceps Leah does that
give you a little more torque for a hand
drops I'm not sure if it's easy for Cain
in 2018 but it's curious if you got any
feedback from any male parties on that
activity I told you okay well this guy's
Canadian and not allowed in our country
do you notice uh but I'll take some I'll
take something from that question do you
notice like a like skills when you get
back home you're like oh this is so easy
like I am I'm cycling oh really yeah
yeah you get on a bike and your legs
just go around around you go whoa
suddenly so easy
mm-hm just you have great thigh muscles
your thigh dup yeah glutes and your butt
it's just a machine like on a plane
crash you'd be the first one eating yeah
like it would eat you they'd cook you
first you're like oh we're definitely
having that tonight we don't you want
the fattiest first I don't think so I
don't know it's a big grisly sister or
brother out there you know yeah I want
to ham down on something for cousin oh
you'd have to beat it you have tenderize
it I'm not gonna hit okay look I'll lead
a ladies back to man McFly this is why
men do barbecue right I'll need a femur
off of you know I'll snack on somebody's
uh you know I'll smack on a glute on a
plain Beckham but I'm not beating a
woman
yeah tenderize for me but the women
tenderize after I wrote the Atlantic my
friend in London oozes shiatsu master he
was like Jesus look at the size of your
hands and of course I immediately went
like this but you know you growing
muscles in your hands like my hand said
I pity anyone who wants to marry me
because I have big hands oh yeah it's
gonna get a special never animator
centimeter a ring yeah but but rowing is
there's a huge misconception that rowing
is upper-body it's not so if you row a
boat in a lake or a river it's 80% legs
20% upper body it's that's quite heavily
the other way for rowing an ocean it's
about 60 40 60 legs 40% arms because
you're getting jostled do you feel just
jacked when you get home
oh no you were stripped of everything oh
wow so you you you are actually eating
your body after a while fat first muscle
next then bone density oh I'd have them
since I'm where I am if I were in
Thailand I'd have that marrow first boy
if somebody went there and I had to eat
them after in the Atlantic I got jobs
modeling in New York you did I was
skinnier than some of the models Wow and
I had that tan oh yeah but I couldn't
cope with New York it was like I mean
been in solitary confinement or a rock
concert it was just I just couldn't cope
oh I can't imagine the dichotomy and I
don't even know if that's the right word
but of going from a place like the ocean
and then being in a busy place like a
city I think I would lose my mind yeah I
think a farm somewhere over the trees
Green is what you want oh yeah how great
green looks so green when you get to it
doesn't it yeah and it smells great
usually it smells like a garden that's
just been freshly washed or freshly
rained on oh I just let somebody shoot a
[ __ ] bazooka full of fruit straight
into my face right yeah I would love
salad anything fresh if I even the word
fresh I enjoy offshore fresh really
fresh yeah and people's words mean more
to you suddenly because you get to hear
them is there something about that like
hearing someone talk well any of the
words are sent to the boat by messages
have so much more meaning if I have to
be really careful what messages get
through because something that's
flipping or a joke can be taken of
completely the wrong way right [ __ ] you
yeah over this for a month so they need
to go in those four guidelines was an
information entertainment and then love
and care like we're really proud of you
and I hope you're you know eating and
drinking and that kind of stuff and you
know actually that's really what
everybody needs information
entertainment love and care yeah so
that's a good rule for life
those are great rules for life um may be
better right handbook off the back of
this Oh a handbook she said to that last
guy I called in so anyway he's right yes
I have really strong hands and I've
actually thought about doing massage
after this but not that kind okay oh and
I'll tell them when I go to a place here
I say do not touch my crotch I say that
right when I go in the door I say kotti
only Oh like any place yeah everywhere
oh I say it even if I just go to the UH
California Pizza Kitchen all
look I don't know what you guys are
selling these don't know um but yeah but
you couldn't really come back and you
could win a thumb wrestling championship
yeah see a really strong cause well if
you ever go on a short row let me know
why you want to come um yeah I get out
there I would probably one of yeah I
don't want to do like a lot of chores
and everything on the boat you'd have to
sit where you're told and do nothing
cuz there's no space oh man so be like
being think on play just sit there and
you could like loll around the cabin
drinking beer and yeah yeah yeah you'd
be fine I could figure something out
that would take a support boat so that
you can get off and go okay five minutes
of this I'm done there we go
I might need this apart my whole life
man this this show is my support boat
Lea didn't we can find you we'll share
all your social media elements and stuff
but where can people find you at Rolly a
row row lea ro li eh
yeah like run Forrest run yeah only a
row Roley a row if that came organically
people like Roly a row and I'm like
that's great I'm gonna use that and
that's the same on everything Instagram
patreon is Rolly a row patreon for
forward slash Rolly row and everything
is really true
awesome we'll make a donation and we
will and we just appreciate you so much
for coming in and making me just think
about yeah when I think about y'all just
think of like you know like there's just
this lady out there on the water you
know and she just get to be in the
moonlight it just feels like man I'll be
so jealous
you know I'm gonna call in and let me
wonder the questions for your show
fascinating if you like Leah from
mid-pacific is calling in with a
question for your next guest okay great
let's have an update every now yeah just
to hear some hear lea rowing um good
luck out there thank you yeah thank you
so much for for coming in and chatting
with me thanks
yes I'm with all of us yeah completing
the Gong Canada yeah Wow there you go
guy
Ottawa like I just cooking some chicken
he said what a creep huh who's cooking
some chicken just asking you a lot
perverted
[Music]
little town for me to sell their parking
brake and let myself
[Music]